merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors pour commencer
que sait-on de ces textes employés de
l'ambassade d'arabie saoudite qui aurait
aidé les pirates de l'air du 11
septembre
très peu de choses d'abord parce que
l'information vient juste d'être connue
par accident et c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle à la fois pour leur avis
services mais également pour
l'administration trump parce que cela va
le mettre dans l'embarras
d'autant que les relations entre les
deux pays était déjà très distendus
depuis quelques mois sur la question
notamment du pétrole mais pas seulement
et puis l affaire de la suite une pardon
de la sphère au cachot guy et donc ça
vient un très mauvais moment et cela
peut contribuer à la fois à mettre en
difficulté le monsieur trump pour la
poche pour sa réélection qui devrait en
principe dont l'élection présidentielle
intervient à la fin de cette année en
novembre 2020 et également pour le
prince héritier mohammed bin salman qui
fait face à une contestation sourde
certes mais une contestation interne à
la famille royale
alors on va y revenir effectivement sur
cette conséquence mais le rapport du fbi
a été rendue publique par négligence
comment comprendre qu'une telle
négligence puisse avoir lieu à ce niveau
là eh ben vous voyez même même dans les
pays les mieux gérés et les plus
administrés comme c'est le cas notamment
pour cette agence de renseignement
intérieur le fbi il peut parfois y avoir
des accidents
il semblerait il faut rester prudent
naturellement tant qu'on n'a pas
davantage d'informations mais il
semblerait que ce soit une négligence de
la part des avocats qui ont provoqué la
divulgation du nom de cet officiel
saoudien alors selon le porte parole de
l'association des victimes des attentats
le villa et tente 2
dissimuler l'implication de l'arabie
saoudite est ce que cette hypothèse est
plausible selon vous oh bah oui je pense
qu' il n'y a pas beaucoup de doutes sur
7 sur ce sujet puisque cela peut encore
une fois mettre en péril les relations
entre les deux pays
d'autant que l'arabie saoudite
aujourd'hui entraîné je dirais dans un
élan de diversification de ses relations
internationales et de ses alliances
entraînée par le voisin émirati le
prince zayed est aujourd'hui dans une
situation où il pourrait éventuellement
se détourner de cette alliance qui date
de 1935 et qui est qui devient de plus
en plus difficile puisque les américains
notamment sur la question judiciaire
sont très très sourcilleux très
pointilleux et très exigeant on s'en est
rendu compte
lorsqu'a éclaté la sphère du journaliste
jay matra shogi qui collaborait
rappelons le au washington post
la journal américain alors on connaît
aussi vous le rappeliez les tensions
entre les usa et l'arabie saoudite avec
la guerre du prix du pain du pétrole est
ce que cette affaire risque t'elle
d'envenimer davantage les relations
pression économique notamment
sega probablement cela va clairement
envenimé les relations entre les deux
pays sur le plan diplomatique ça c'est
clair parce que la presse américaine va
enquêter pour tenter d'en savoir
davantage cela va les emmener d
envenimer également sur la question
judiciaire juste les familles des
victimes se sont constituées et qu' ils
vont chercher à savoir qu'elle a été
l'implication réelle du gouvernement
saoudien ou de la famille royale
et puis cela va avoir oxydé implication
américaine sur le plan interne puisque
l'administration les administrations qui
se sont succédé depuis 2000 2000
1 ne pouvait pas ignorer l'implication
saoudienne et la responsabilité dans les
attentats du 11 septembre
donc sur différents niveaux et puis sur
le plan économique
évidemment donc il va y avoir il va y
avoir des ramifications ça c'est très
clair il est beaucoup trop tôt
aujourd'hui pour dire quelles en seront
les conséquences réelles et si cela va y
aura un coup de froid
mais est-ce que cela va mettre en péril
durablement cette relation qui s'est
forgée sur des intérêts très précis
c'est encore là aussi trop tôt pour le
dire
merci beaucoup qui avaient envie d'avoir
partagé votre expertise rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de recherche à
l'institut prospective et sécurité de
l'ordre